how did you get your first hollywood
writing job
it was a fluke a freak occurrence
um i it was actually a script that i had
written 10 years before it was my first
script
and i had gotten an agent with my first
script i'd gotten very lucky
i knew someone who knew someone who
showed it to an agent who
picked me up as their client but they
could not get me i
there had been a very small option
during the 10 years other than that
i was office temping and administrative
assistanting and doing some development
work for indie companies
and i was beginning to think i should
stop i should just
because i was actually planning to
become a teacher like maybe a high
school teacher or college teacher if i
could
because at least i would have summer
vacations to write
it was always what can i do to support
my writing that never stopped
but the idea of becoming a screenwriter
stopped because i was like
why keep beating my head against the
wall i had written a bunch of scripts
i had an agent i if i wasn't making it
maybe i should quit
um but the the first script i had
written all of my scripts were
well liked by the people who read them
they just were like this is really good
we just can't make it for
a billion reasons there's always a
billion reasons why people can't do
things
um but a an independent producer who
really loved one of my scripts and i had
done some rewrites with her
um her name was mae wathridge and she
um took a job at tribeca films when it
was just starting
and um she had to
say that she was stopping her
independent career
and going to work for tribeca but
she had the opportunity uh she met with
someone who works with billy crystal
who was looking to work with de niro on
uh
what turned out to be analyzed this
eventually after i failed them
um but they they were looking to work
together and may
slipped them my script and
they loved it and they said this this
would work very well
and so all of a sudden tribeca
had to pick me up as like oh i guess
we'll pick up his script
to take so all of a sudden from
being about to quit i was working with
big hollywood stars and my agent lisa
calamaro
arranged a fabulous option and first
step deal and all of a sudden i didn't
have to work temp for a year
while i did rewrites on that project
which went
so fast downhill and died completely and
the um they wanted changes that i didn't
know how to make
and i had worked for 10 years learning
how to write
what was in my head and i had never
learned about the part of hollywood
writing
where somebody says change that that
wasn't even on my radar and this was a
long time ago this was in the late 1980s
it just never occurred to me that like
someone would say
as they did it was the story was about a
divorcing couple
a couple who had gotten divorced and
remarried and um
divorced again and over political
differences
and then the guy gets involved in
espionage and politics and things and so
their divorce
the topic of their divorce becomes the
subject of the thriller
and so it was sort of a thriller
romantic comedy and
the note was can you take out the
divorce
and and it was a completely legitimate
note
in one way if you were a flexible
hollywood writer who understood how to
rethink things there are ways to do that
and i actually did that later on another
script
where i took out what i considered the
center of the story
at the time i had never had that
question raised
and i tried so hard i i was just like i
got to do this this is my big break and
i'm
blowing it um but i couldn't i wrote an
entire script i've actually it's the
only thing i've ever written
that i have never looked at since it's
30 years now i wrote it i literally
cried through much of the writing like
i was a basket case because i was
writing something that i didn't know
what the center was
because for me the center of this story
the reason that everyone was doing
something
was because of this couple trying to get
back together
when you take that out all you've got is
a bunch of people chasing each other
in funny ways but still wasn't enough to
make a scene
i wrote a script i have no idea if it's
readable
but i got immediately fired uh the
script went
on on the shelf and they hired new
writers
and for three years they held on to it
and
niro and crystal wisely moved on did
analyze this
it was a good choice on their part um
and at the end of that
three years i got my script back which
was cool because
i had been well paid to let them have it
for three years
i had never seen any of the rewrites
that were done
after i did it so therefore i was i was
allowed to take everything i had done
that was my property
the script i the draft i done for them
was their property because they paid me
for it
but the option was over and i
just started sending it out again and i
so many people loved it and
got so close to production so many times
but what it taught me was the thing that
i thought writing was about which is you
imagine stuff
and you get it down as good as you can
and then they pay you and they make it
that's not how the industry works the
industry works that you
do all that stuff and then you start to
collaborate with other people
and if you can't do that part if you
can't learn how to use those same
creative skills
on demand for things you may not think
are great then they'll find someone who
can
does that sound depressing it's not
meant to it's meant to it's meant to say
learn the mechanics of the business
so that you can do the job that's that's
the message i hope is being sent there
is that there is the magic of creativity
and then there's the magic of being
skilled
and knowing how to do the job no matter
what gets thrown at you
well i think it's very important that
you bring up that story because so many
ideas of something sound great
and then when you learn what they
actually are it's much much different
so that's just fascinating so it was a
year that you had to rewrite that or
that was a year process it was a year of
actually this is it's a funny story so
i'll tell it
uh it's embarrassing um i got once i
took out the center of the story
i didn't know what the story would be
and i what i do is that when i don't
know
what i'm going to write i just riff i
think of everything i can i brainstorm
it could be this it could be that you
know we're on a submarine it could be
the submarine's at the bottom of the sea
it could be at the submarine got moved
to dry land where you know everything i
can possibly think i try and get it down
on paper there's no such thing as a bad
idea
until you've figured out what you're
trying to accomplish with it anything's
possible
so i had this huge list of possibilities
of this story
and i didn't know which one they wanted
and i was writing for them
so um i made it into a board game
i actually i was working as an office
temp still so i had access to like a
laminating machine everything
and i made a board and it was like it
was like the game of life where you go
along a path but
this had like multiple branching paths
for each story
and and i tried to lay out all the
different story outlines as a
board game with like cards like if you
pick this you go in this tray
it was the most elaborate creative
stupid thing i've ever done and i
brought it to billy crystal
i got an appointment i flew to los
angeles i gave it to him
and i said this is your story outline
i don't know which one you want and he
was really gracious about it and he was
he was great he was like
you know well now i have something to
put on the wall of my office
but now we actually have to write the
script after work and he gave me advice
and
i worked on it and i did a draft and it
was all fine but
that was how little i understood the job
the job by the way is making choices
the point is when i when you lay out the
000 possible stories you have to make a
choice
everything is a choice every choice has
a price you have to learn to get
comfortable
with making choices over and over and
over again
everything in creative work is
i'm going to choose this and not that if
i choose this that means that i can't
have a happy ending
if i choose this it means i can't talk
about communism versus
capitalism you know whatever it is that
you want to do it's a choice
and when you make that choice certain
things fall away
but other things become stronger that's
the creative process and everyone gets
very afraid
of that what if i make the wrong choice
the coolest thing is whatever a writer
is to get comfortable with
you know what it's a choice i'm gonna
make it i make it
judging i know that the producers want
this well
no more choice that's what i'm doing if
you don't know for sure
you change you take the choice and you
follow that path
you're gambling maybe it'll work maybe
it won't but it's better to make the
choice
and be creative and try and find your
solutions
than to try and do both that's the one
thing you can't do
got to make a choice and you have to
live with the price
when they asked you to take out which
what was the center of the story which
is the couple getting divorced and
getting back together
did they didn't tell you what to replace
it with they didn't know
when people give you notes they don't
know how to fix it
they they just like you know that seems
seems a little wrong or sometimes
they'll know how to fix it but it's
not what you thought would be like you
might have a better one
it doesn't matter what matters is that
everyone is going to see things
differently and most notes are
this isn't working not do this
if they would do this then it's like
i'll do that
most notes are that's not making sense
or that's too slow or that's too fast
but how you actually solve it
that's your task and so for you
that was so new it never occurred to me
it was you know people didn't know that
much about screenwriting in the
late 80s early 90s like it wasn't as
much of a thing
people didn't do it as much as they do
now now
everybody writes scripts um and frankly
everyone should because now everyone can
make them
um but at the time the experience of
being a professional writer was not very
well known
um there were only a handful of books
and in fact the first time i came to la
um i was my agent had come out and she
had set me up with meetings
and everyone said to me your work is
good
you could work here if you moved here um
but you would be have to get used to
writing things that didn't get made
because at the time
that was how development worked they
would develop 50 scripts and make one
which meant 49 writers were writing a
script that was going to be put on a
drawer never seen again
and they would be highly paid and they
would be well respected and maybe
one of them would get lucky at one of
your scripts would would hit
but you never knew some people had a
full career
never getting anything made and that
blew my mind i was like
i'm not going to work a whole year on a
script and not have anyone see it
which of course that's the business
that's the job
but at the time i didn't know i had no
clue and it took me a while to process
that
and to recognize that as a day job goes
pretty cool you learn a lot on it and
you get paid to do the thing you love
but
it may get put on the shelf you may
never see it again
when you came back to them with other
ideas which
could be the center of the story did
they not like it or that was the board
game
all right this is
the the process by which this happens is
that the people who are in charge like
if you're a star
or a director and you're supervising
writers
you know that you're not a writer and so
you just try to guide them as some are
better than others
and it's it's the writer's job to
translate
the notes that's part of being a
professional screenwriter
is recognizing that people are going to
tell you stuff and you have to figure
out
what i believe is you have to figure out
how to turn it into scenes
everything about screenwriting is how to
think in scenes
if you can figure out how to make a
scene out of an idea or a desire or
whatever it is that somebody says
then you can be a professional writer
and um
so very often the people in charge will
say like honestly
you know i know what end result i want
but i don't know how to get there that's
your job
um so that was a lot of the notes were
like that and in fact i said
i said here's the thing when it really
comes down to it there's a big
there's a binary choice there's a this
or that you know
is it this ending or that ending and the
note was well could it be both
what are you going to do so eventually i
just chose
i actually think this board game is kind
of cool but it was great i wish
i don't know if i have a copy of it i
think i gave him the only copy
that's kind of a neat idea i mean if
someone had the time to make the board
game that that would be
yeah absolutely no i mean essentially
it's create your own story which is now
a completely legitimate
creative project you know you could you
can
you know digitally you can make a story
that you could do that with
i think it's called a video game you
know and um so i just was
decades ahead of my there you go i
should have been designing games
you